good morning good morning today the
college adopted a whole package on our
digital strategy it is the white book
for artificial intelligence and the data
strategy we want to boost European
artificial intelligence by attracting
more than 20 billion euros per year for
the next decade to create these European
Union data spaces and cloud
infrastructure we want to trigger
investment of four to six billion euros
artificial intelligence must serve
people and therefore artificial
intelligence must always comply with
people's rights we want to encourage our
businesses our researchers the
innovators the entrepreneurs to develop
artificial intelligence and we want to
encourage our citizens to feel confident
to use it we have to unleash this
potential